ええと、私たちはライブのように見える
ので、あなたは私たちがライブになることを
本当にすばやくツイートする
つもりです。
今日のビデオのタイトル
今日のビデオで私はblackmagic製品
を使用してYouTubeビデオを作成する方法について話し
ますええ
と私はこれをやっていますちょっと
ちょっと普通のblackmagicクルー私はこれを
ライブで
やっています いくつか
の製品の機能の種類を説明するのに最適な方法な
ので
、チャットを少し見
ていきますが、ほとんどの場合
、ワークフローを通じて、ハードウェアとソフトウェアの側面でビデオを作成する方法について話します。
うまくいけば、これが便利だと思う人もいるでしょう。
これは
私にとって本当に感情的なテーマです。
ライターとして、
私を刺激
するものは私が注意を払わ
なければならないものであることがわかったからです。 良い
映画か、もし私が聞いたら
本当に心に響く曲です。
何年にもわたって、自分の主な職業としてクリエイティブなライティングをしようとしていることを学びました。その
ようなことに注意を払う
と、同じような感情
を自分の中に反映できるようになります。
私がyoutubeを始めたとき、私が
検索しなければならなかったものの1つは明らか
にカメラでした、そして私は
あなたが主要な日本のカメラ会社を知っているすべての異なる
ええとを調べ
ました。 彼らは皆、
あなたが十分以上に知っているように見えました
が、ああ、私は少し静かです。
マイク
を少し上げます。うまくいけば
、カメラの1つを探していたので、もう少し良くなることを願って
います。 私が見つけたの
はこのカメラ
で、これはブラックマジック
ポケットシネマカメラと呼ばれています。これは
2013年か2014年頃
か、このカメラが生成したカムの画像を見たときのことです。
私にとっては芸術のように感じました。このビデオ
は、このカメラで撮影された
生のシネマと生の映像を使用して撮影されたフェアのよう
な夜のシーンでした。 私
がこの時点で探していたカメラ
と私はこれが安っぽく
聞こえることを知っています私はあなたがこれを言うために支払われていることを知っているように聞こえることを知って
いますそしてblackmagicはあなたが見ようとしているアイテムの多くを送りました
がそれは 私がこのカメラを購入することになった
理由は、私がそのビデオを見て、
これはフィルムのように見えると思ったからです。これはデジタルビデオのようには見えません。これは
美しい
フィルム
のように見えるので、大丈夫だと思いました。
私のyoutubeビデオを作成するためにこのカメラを使用するつもりです
、そして私はそれをええとebayで使用して購入しました
私は2015年に400のように思います
本当に失敗しましたが、
今日は上で話したいです ut私が
この製品
とこの製品をどのように使用するか、そして
あなたがユーチューバー
としての私のワークフローをスピードアップするためにあなたが効果的に見よう
としている他の
ものをどのように使用するか
私が今やろうとしている最初のこと
は、彼
がカメラバンドのブランドや編集
プログラムについて話して
いることです。私はすべてについて話しているので、カメラの使い方について話しているのです。
どのように
カラーグレーディングを適用するか
多くの異なるものを適用するので
、私が向きを変えるつもりだと見てみましょ
う多分これをそのままにしておくことができます
それは大丈夫
ですそれで私が今やろうとしているのは
このカメラを
ライブで親切に接続することです
私が現在ライブストリームに使用している2番目の製品を紹介
します。このカメラを
ここにあるこの小さなマウント
に接続し、机
に向けて接続します。 私がここに持っているこれらのケーブルのうちの2つは
、私たちがこれをやっているという事実を何度も思います
ライブは、
これらのものがどれほど強力であるかを物語っているので、これ
をオンにします。これで、現在オンになっています。
これから、
このカメラに切り替えます。
これが私たちのカメラです。
接続したばかり
なので、メインカメラに戻りましょう。
これが私のメイン
カメラです。この2番目のカメラをここに接続しました。このカメラを通して
見ているもの
は、画面の右下にあるこの小さなウィンドウにあり
ます。 ここで
この製品はここでatemミニプロと呼ばれ
、
これは多くの異なるものですが、これはhdmi
スイッチャーですが、ストリーミングとカメラの切り替え用に特別に
構築された小さな小さなコンピューターのようなものでもある
ので、
明らかに私はちょうど私ができることをすることができます 画面の右下
にあるこのデバイスのボタンを押すと、
接続されているさまざまなものを
循環できるので、メイン画面をあなたたちのようにすることができますか
？ 私を見て これを
メイン画面にすることができます。
私がこの製品を本当に気に入っている理由の1つは、
私がobsのようなプログラムの大ファンではないため
、クラッシュする傾向があり、
非常に気難しいからです。
だから私はそれを可能にする専用のハードウェアを持っていることを非常に好み
ますそれは私がああちょっとエリックとカイリーをストリーミングすることを可能にします
1秒もある
ので、今度はワークフロー全体を見て、
どのようにスピードアップするかについて話します
が、
これをすぐにオフ
にしましょう。 このカメラの
レンズをこの超ワイド下部レンズですばやく外
に出すと、物事がすぐに
異なって見え、おそらくもっと涼しくなり
ますが、私が着ているスウェットパンツのようなくだらないええとユニクロが見えるかもしれません
ので
、カメラのレンズを切り替えましょ
う 大丈夫ショット今、私たちは完了しました 真っ白
で、まだ私の声が聞こえるはずです
が、レンズを接続して
みましょう。すぐに幅が広くなるので、
これもクールなショット
です。この
種のショットが好きです。 もっとダイナミックに
大丈夫今度はカラーグレーディングとlutsについて話しましょ
うそれはおそらくそれを行う
前に物事を説明するためのおそらく最良の方法だと思い
ます
私がYouTubeで通常のコメディービデオに使用しているカメラ
です。これは私
がYouTubeで使用しているセットアップで
あり、画像は
本当に真っ白で本当に色あせているように見えます。
飽和状態を超えて本当に
使用できないのは、おそらくそれを説明するための最良の方法
です。
それは、カラーグレーディングについて何か知っている
場合、すでに見栄えの良いビデオを撮影すると
、そのvの色を変更するのが難しいためです。 事後のideoなので
、この
カメラで今見ているものは、
私が作成
してカメラに焼き付けたカスタム
ルックのようなものなので、今すぐこのカメラを元の状態に戻します。 デフォルトなので
、皆さんが見ることができる
ので、カメラをすばやくポップオフし
ますが、
これをすばやく実行します。うまくいけば
、これは私のカメラがデフォルトでどのように見えるかを示してい
ます。
今のところ、1秒前よりも大幅に悪化している
と言えます。その理由は
、組み込みの色は
、カメラ会社が
すべての一般的なシナリオに最適であると考えているものですが、私が
先に進めてきたものであることが多いためです。 そして
、
この特定のカメラとこの
特定のセットアップのために特別に作成されたので、
今あなたは日本の
紙の壁が白く見えることを知っています
、そしてええと、
おそらく
ホワイトバランスがずれているかもしれないので、画像全体が少し黄色に見えますが
今私は このカメラ用に特別に
作成した他の外観に戻す
ので、元に戻し
ましょう。戻ってきたので、明らかにこれ
は
はるかに映画的
で、このカメラの驚くべきことの1つです。
ポケットシネマカメラ4k
は
、カメラによって生成される画像に、カメラに
lutsを焼き付けることができるように構築できるので、ここで少し技術的に
なります。皆さんの多く
は少しです。 少し
、ええ、これはもっと青と青と黄色のように見えますが、それは
一種の良い補完的な
色です
ので、明らかにあなたがyoutubeをしているなら、あなたは
画像をできるだけダイナミックで面白いものに見せたい
と思います
それ
は安全だと思います 言い
ますが、通常のコメディビデオからわかるように、通常のカメラに戻ると、
これは
本当に本当に色あせて見えます。
これは、
コメディ
セットアップのこの画像がログファイルと呼ばれているためです。
ogファイルは、
何も
していなければひどい見た目ですが、ログファイル
はポストプロダクションで非常に簡単に編集できる
ので、コンピューター
側では、
fujifilm fujiの色はとても
良いですが、
たとえば あなたはフジカメラのように購入しました、
そしてあなたは多くの人がフジフィルムは
フジがいくつかの最高の色を持っていると言い
ますが、あなた
がそれをそれほど好きではなかったらどうし
ますか たとえば、
これをもう少し
青くしたいと思っていて
、画像がすでに見栄えが良い場合は色を少し調整したいと思っ
たので、事後に色を調整するのは非常に難しい
ので、人々はこれで撮影します
ログ
画像のようなものです。このように撮影
すると、画像を編集しているときに画像を希望どおりに表示するのが非常に簡単になるため、次に
何をするかを説明
します。
私たちは行くつもり
です
私は先に行くつもりです
dコンピュータの画面
に移動し、ここに移動します。
これは、前に見たa10 mini proを制御する方法の1つである
ため、
このデバイスを使用して現在
ストリーミングを行っており、いくつかの高度な処理を実行できます。
ええと
、あなたが現在右下隅で見ているこのウィンドウのサイズを変更する
ように、ええ、ビデオはポストプロダクションでプロで見栄えするために見栄えが悪い必要があり
ます
はい、
それはあなたが試しているならそれを説明するのに最適な方法
です ビデオを特定の方法で表示するために、
私たちが何をするかをもう一度教えてください
私のプロジェクトの1つに行きましょう
私は最近、あなたが日本にいるという34のサインというビデオを作成した
ので、そのプロジェクトを開い
てあなた みんなは私がファイナルカットプロを使ってビデオを編集しているのを見ることができます
そしてファイナルカットをクリックする
とそれはオフになるはず
です 本当に
速いので、今すぐタイムラインに戻ってきます
コンピューターをミュートし
ますが、ビデオを作成して
いるときは、これが
ファイナルカットプロ内の外観であり、ここに表示されているこの画像
は
、カラーグレードがすでに適用されている場合の外観です。
画像です
が、カラーグレードが適用される前にどのように見えるかを見て
みましょう。
これをクリックして、
ビデオ設定
に移動します。これらの効果をすばやく無効にする
ので、画像は次のようになります。 まったく
違う権利と
繰り返しますが、これは画像がどのように見えるかです
これはカメラからの画像がどのように見えるか
ですが、このように見えるので、画像を引っ張って、
私が望むように見せることができ
ます ビデオを編集しているときのように見える
ので、これをもう一度クリック
すると、まったく異なって見えるので
、バランスを適用しまし
た。カラーバランスを適用しました。カラー
ホイールを適用しました。カスタムのlutを適用しました。
テーブルを上げて
、肌の色も少し調整しました
が
この特定の種類の外観に
は向かわなかったとしましょう。これは多くの皆さんが知っている私のコメディックな外観
ですが、これをオフにし
ます。これらをすべて削除して
、このビデオをカラーグレードします。
ふりがなを作るつもりだったので、ふりがなの場合は
、日本語の知識を使って日本語の発音を教えて
、別の色を探し
ます。もう少し
明るい色を探します。
これはすべてを説明する上で重要なので、
このカラーグレードの
音声学のカラーグレードをこのクリップに適用すると、クリップの上に
表示されるこの点線が表示され
ます。
これは、
このファイルをレンダリングしているコンピュータです。
はこの新しいカラーグレードを処理し
て終了しましたが
、この特定のクリップを
非常に
長くすると、コンピュータが
この
特定のクリップ全体をこれらの色で処理するのに非常に長い時間がかかります。
60分のビデオのように撮影する場合
は、カラーグレードを適用して、
どのように見えるかを確認してから、そこから好きな
外観または個人のテイクを選択します。つまり、
約20分待つ必要があります。
動画のレンダリングが完了するまでに数分ほどかかります。
クリエイターとしては
、何かが起こるのを待つのにかなりの時間がかかります。
その間、メールでその種類のアカウントを確認するなど、他のことを行う
ことができ
ます。
しかし
、色補正とレンダリング
により、ビデオを
このように再び表示するため
、ビデオの外観を変更する
と、コンピュータのプロセッサ
とグラフィックカードに非常に集中する
ことがあり
ます。場合によっては、コンピュータがクラッシュするチャットを見ることができ
ます。 私がやりたいの
は、ビデオをレンダリングするときです。
ビデオをレンダリングするだけ
です。これは、変更できるという事実がなぜできるのかについて話したときに、再び約20分ほどかかります。
独自のカスタム
lutを選択
し、この特定のカメラから出力されるフッテージに焼き付けます。
これは、ポストプロダクションでビデオをレンダリングする必要がないため
、
20分程度で完全に取り除くことができるため
です。 コンピューターがカラーグレードを適用するのを待って
いるので、20分が経過した
ので、それは非常に大きな問題です
が、これは、物事が少し面白くなり始める場所であり、
これは非常に
技術的ですが、ええと
クリエイターとして、ワークフロー
をスピードアップするためにできる小さなことが長期的
には非常に大きな違いを生む
ので、私は
これに本当に情熱を注いでいます。
これ
は私のポケットシネマカメラから出てくる画像で
、YouTubeビデオを作成するために使用しました
。ほとんど
の人はおそらく知っていると思います
が、残念ながら
この画像は非常に古いカメラから出ているためです。
この古いカメラには、新しいカメラと同じよう
に、その色補正をフッテージに焼き付ける機能があり
ません。これ
は、いわば私の内なるアーティストが話しているようなものですが、
個人的には見た目を好みます。
古いカメラの方
が新しいカメラよりも
少しざらざらして
いるように見えるので、
私自身の個人的な意見
では、外に出て1 300を購入するのではなく、少しフィルムのように見えます。
カメラ
は、色補正が適用されるのを待つ20分ほどを取り除くために、
この特定の
カメラを使い続けるつもりだと言っただけ
で、ビデオが
ビデオ編集をしているときにレンダリングしますが、
最近別の製品
に気づきました。これ
はミニコンバーターsdi
からhdmi 6g
と呼ばれ、これ
により
、どのカメラでも色補正を行うことができます。 だからw つまり、フッテージ
を焼くことができないこの古いカメラを再び持っているのですが、これを使用
すると、色補正を直接
行うことが
できます。 これを接続
するために申し訳ありませんが、これはすべて
を接続するのに
少し時間がかかります。
きれいなフィードレコードを監視します。
これは少し
奇妙です。 その
sdi大丈夫だから
今私が以前に見ていたその画像に戻ると
ええそれらは私の
子供です
ええとベビーシッターは今ここにいる
ので私が以前に見ていたその画像に戻ると
今は次のようになります
これで、以前よりもかなりパンチが効き
、基本的
にはコメディビデオのときのように見えるので、
ここを歩いてみましょう。皆さんはそれがどのように見えるかを確認できます。
照明を調整します。
あなたたちがseできるように部屋はすぐに本物
すべてを見て、
マイクもオンにします。うまくいけば、
これがすべて計画どおりに進むことを願っ
ています。これをライブで行っている
ので、いくつか問題が発生する可能性がありますが、
これを実行してみ
ましょう。 私のラップトップまたは私の
ipadは、何か問題があった場合に知らせて
くれるので、オフにし
ます。これで、基本的
には通常のようになります。
適用されるべきだったので、
うまくいけば、
このマイクも拾っているように見えます。
この
マイクはおそらく片側にしか入っていないことに気づきまし
た。設定を少し調整する必要があるので、
元に戻しましょう。
私の通常のコンピューターのセットアップに移り、問題
を説明できるよう
になりました。戻ってきたので
、もう一度部屋の照明
をオンにし
て、マイクをオフにして、オーディオ
を通常の状態に戻す必要があります。
davinci resolveを使用して、ビデオを編集
しすぎ
ます。 すぐにわかります
が、基本的に
私が得ようとしているの
は、
そのsdiからhdmiへのコンバーターを使用する際に、
実際に
購入したものを自分のお金で購入し
たことです。
私はそれが欲しいかどうかを確認
し
、それ
が私がやりたいことをしたことを理解すると
すぐ
に私は自分のお金ですぐに購入したので、彼らは実際に私
がこれを購入したことさえ知りません
ええと、
私はこのビデオを使っ
て彼らのさまざまな製品について話しているのですが、追加の製品を求めた場合
、私がこれも購入したのは驚き
です。
メガネは、
おそらく無料で送ってくれるでしょう
。なぜなら、彼らは
本当にクールな会社で
あり、私は彼らと一緒に仕事をするのが本当に好き
だからです。
今この画面でオンにすると、それ
が前後に変わります m
これはあなたが現在見ている本当に本当にフラットな画像です
そしてそれはそれをそれに変えます
それは本当に
本当に本当に大きな違いです
そして映像が
このように見えるときすでに
そうそう卵ヨルチュがオフになっているとき私は回すべきです
つまり
、コンピューターがビデオを処理するのを待つ必要がない
ので、150ドルのこの単一の製品
は、おそらく200ドルのようなものだった
ので、人々
は非常に高価な3千4のようにコンピューター全体を購入します。
あなたのコンピュータが映像を処理するのに長い時間がかかるので、特に編集プロセスをスピードアップするための千五千ドルの高価なコンピュータですが、
このデバイスが行うこと
は
、あなたが購入できるようにそれ自体で色の処理を処理することです これは
、コンピュータをアップグレードして
それに多くのお金を費やすのではなく、200ドルで、
これを購入してもスピードが出ないので
、レンダリングプロセスがスピードアップしません。
レンダリングプロセスを
完全に取り除くので、これはゲームチェンジャーのようなもの
です。これは、私が作成する
すべてのビデオに対して20分または30分の作業を言い
たいので、これは私にとって
非常に非常
に非常に重要なデバイス
です。 他にもいくつか話をしたいのです
が、お金があまりない場合は
、コンピューターをアップグレードするのではなく
、これらの1つ
を法制化して、そのような映像を撮る
ことができます。 通常はこの
ように見え
、編集プロセス中にそのステップ全体を取り除くことができます。これも
明らかに非常に大きな
問題です
が、今私たちが試してできること
は、オーディオ側について話すことです。
私が現在撮影しているこのカメラ
は皆さんが見ているものであり、
実際にレンズを他のレンズに戻すつもりです。
これは
少し
うまくいっているので、楽しみのために元に戻しましょう。
このカメラ
そのy あなたは現在これを聞いてい
ます
、そしてそれはブラック
マジックポケットシネマカメラ4k
と呼ばれていますそしてこのカメラの本当に素晴らしいことの1つ
はそれが
ファンタム電源を備えた内蔵のxlrミニ入力を持っている
ので私の友人の一人です
トラッシュテイストの
トラッシュテイストからジョーイとギグクでコナーを
知っていると思います。ツイッターでかなりの量のコナーと連絡を取り
ました。少し話をしましたが、彼
はオフィスツアーを見ました。
近くから見ると彼はしわが寄っているように見えます
ええ私はもっと食べる必要があると思います
がとにかく
彼が私がええと青いイエティマイクを使っていることを知ったとき彼
は私に怒ってあなたがxlrマイクを使わなければならないと言ったとき彼は
コナーを逸脱します だから私は大丈夫だと言った
ので
彼は私にいくつかの推奨事項を与えましたそして
それから
私も自分の研究をしました
そして私はこのカメラ
またはこのマイクをここに持ってきましたこれは
オクタバと呼ばれていますそれはロシア人です
コンデンサーマイクを作ってみたと思います
本当にいい音
がする
もっと私は
クリエイターとして私に興味があるかどうかはわかりませ
んが、このようなxlrマイクを使用すると
、ほとんどのカメラにxlr入力がないため、ほとんどのカメラに接続
できません。
mこのカメラに戻って
、私が録画しているこのカメラをお見せします。
皆さんは私のセットアップを確認できます。
このカメラはここにあります。この黒い
魔法のポケットシネマカメラ4k
このカメラに
は xlr mini inputは、
この高価でより良いサウンドのマイク
をカメラに直接接続できることを意味します。これは、古いカメラで行っ
ていたことの1つであるため
、これで知っているコメディービデオであるため、多くの問題が解消されます。 セットアップで
は、オーディオと
ビデオを
別々に録音してから、それらを同期
して投稿する必要があり、
時々奇妙なタイミングの問題が発生
し
、オーディオを修正する必要があり、
それは常に多くの時間を要しました 投稿
でiiはそれが気に入らなかっ
たし、youtuberとして
デスクトップを見せ
てあげるよ
本当に
速い
大丈夫私はまだ
大丈夫だと思いますええ申し訳ありませんが
私は18ミニプロの上の間違ったボタンを誤って押し
まし
た 私たちは今は良いはず
ですが、このような素敵なxlrマイクを使用したい場合
は
、今すぐデスクトップに切り替え
ます。ここにあるよう
に、3つの異なるビデオプロジェクトを知っています。 私のコンピュータはすでに
、それは私が私のキャマーから映像を落としているときを意味します
マイクを
コンピューターに接続する
と、デスクトップに
数十、数十、数十の
異なるファイルが入力されるため
、
オーディオと
ビデオを別々に撮影するとすべてが複雑になり、オーディオ
とビデオを一緒に撮影
すると明らかに問題が発生します 後処理
ではるかに簡単
になりますので
、このカメラをもう一度使用すると、これ
にはxlr入力がありますが、
このカメラに
はxlr入力がありませんが、
このカメラが大好きです。
私のコメディービデオ
の場合、私はそれの外観が本当に好きですが、それ
はxlrマイクであるため、現在そのセットアップで見ているマイクを接続することはできません。
]
このビデオアシスト
モニターとこれ
には実際にxlrミニ入力がある
ので、このデバイス
をこのカメラに接続する
ことで、コメディービデオに使用するこの画像をカメラが撮影
し、xlrを追加できます
非xlrカメラへの入力とそれ
は本当に本当に大きな問題な
ので、これ
もここにあるこのモニターには
ファントムパワーとミニxlr入力があるので、これを
使用してxlrマイクとsdioutを追加できます。
これ
はsdiから
hdmiへのコンバーターであり、lutsをフッテージに焼き付けるためですが、
今私たちが試すことができるの
は
、一緒にカラーグレードを作ってみることです
ので、これは本当に面白いと思います
これは私がどのように行うかです
セットアップでresolveを使用
して、カメラ4に移動します。
また、final cut proを使用します。
このプログラムは
、ビデオを編集するためのアップルプログラムですが、
、ビデオをカラーグレードするために解決します。
カメラを少し下に移動
して、カラーグレードを作成し、
このストリーム中にライブで適用するので
、これらをすべて削除してみましょう。
これが カム映像
は私のblacからのように見えます
kマジックポケットシネマカメラなので
、ここにノードを追加
します。
これは少しうまくいきます。これは
非常に複雑です
が、これを行う方法を知っていると、これを使用する方法を説明し
ます。 これは
誰にとっても理解しやすいので、
これは私の映像がカメラから直接見えるものに近いものです。
次に、影を少し増やして、
このツールを使用してさまざまなことを調整
します。 これにより、画像が非常に
明るくなり、これを下に引くと
画像が非常に暗く
なり
、画面の右隅にあるこれらの各ノードは
、カラーグレーディングプロセスのどこかで目的を果たし
ます。
したがって、この最初のノードはちょうど
すべてのバランスを取り
、すべての外観を整えるような
ものです。最初に適切なベースを取得するために、多かれ少なかれ何を言いますか。
次に、
このノード
は、色のバランスが良くなるように色を少し調整します。
そしてどこで 少し複雑になり始めたの
は、このノードがここにあることです。
この画面に表示されているの
は、私の
肌だけです。肌の色は、ビデオにとって非常に重要
です。その理由は
肌の色が少しオフになっている場合
は、部屋に緑色のライトがあった
か、カメラを適切に設定しなかったなどの理由で、肌の色が少し多すぎ
ます。 本当に本当に
具合が悪い
ように見えるので、このプログラム
解決
でできることは
、肌の色だけを非常に簡単に選択できること
です。おそらくここでこれを見ることができます
が、ここでは飽和度
が57.50に設定され
ていますが、これを上げると 大きな時間のように、
または私がそれを完全に下げると、
今は白黒のようになり
ます
が、飽和度を上げる
と、古いビデオのように見えます
が、肌の色が飽和しすぎている
ので、もう一度私は
私のためにそれを設定します
セットアップええと、それは57.50でしたが、それ
は肌の色調の飽和度の点でかなり良いです、
そしてそうです、そうそう、解決は
顔の色調のためにあなたの顔をリアルタイムでキーイングすることができ
ます すぐにわかります
これは私が作成している一般的な外観の一種であり、
調整します
これをすぐに適用してみて、これが肌の後になります トーンが
適用された後
、カーブに別の調整が加えられました。
これらのカーブは、基本的に
画像のさまざまな部分の明るさを制御します。
これを上げると、
より
明るく明るい部分になります。 画像がはるかに
明るいので、シャツ
の色にあまり影響を与えないことがわかる
ように試してみましょう。しかし、
私の後ろの壁は
今は吹き飛ばされている
ように見えます。同様に、これは暗い部分のようです。 画像
の
これらの影なので、これを引っ張ると
上または下のよう
に、画像の暗い部分のように、
それらがどれほど明るいかが変化するのを見ることができるので、
ここに戻っ
て、次に何をするかを説明します。
ノードこれは
次のレイヤーの
ようなものです。この
垂直線に沿って、この対角線で
はなく、この緑色の点が
この白い点
またはこの白い線
の少し上にあります。これ
は、のハイライトに緑色を追加したためです。 画像は
緑で少し
青なので、この
種類の壁をもう一度見
てください。この青を上げると
壁が青になり
、緑をもう一度上げると それは壁
を一種の緑にする
ので、
私が今使用しているこのセットアップで
これが少し
青のように見える理由は、このカメラの青いライトが青からではない
ためです。
私がちょうどあなたにハイグを上げたのを見せていたように、このカメラを解決して探し
てください hlights私
は画像の青と緑の部分
を上げて、
オレンジとティールのように見せました。これは今少し青に見えます。これは
私が現在着ているこのシャツとの良い補色です。
さて、プログラムに戻りましょう。
これは、ほとんどの人
が興味を持っている、または通常は興味
を持っていることです。ビデオ編集作業などで何かをしたことがある場合は、これが問題です。
あなたはおそらくたくさんのことを聞いたことがあるでしょうし、
それを知らない人
にとっては、サイバーパンクのような
感じで
、画像に追加して作成できる小さな小さなファイルのようなものです。
特定の方法のように見えますそれ
はあなたのビデオのプリセットええと画像のようなものですので私は
現在このlutを持っています
3dlutを見てみましょう
osirisvision6ドットログと呼ばれるこのlutは
私が現在使用しているたくさんのものです
私の見た目のためにからのええと異なるノードのこのチェーンの終わり しかし
、その女を変更した場合、私
たちにできることは
osirisに行きましょう。
たとえば、
このm31の外観を選択する
と、画面の左上の画像がどのように
変化するかを選択します。 私は
m31をクリックしましたが、それは小さな変更でし
たが、そこにあったので
、今は2つの外観の間を循環する
ので、このような異なるlutsを使用する
こと
で、イメージの全体的な感触を実際に変更できます。
試してみましょう。
たとえば、黒と白の
女のように黒と白の外観
が必要な場合は、これを
もう一度実行します。たとえば、それを選択することも、使用できるさまざまなビルド済みの女がたくさんあることを知っていることを選択することも
できます。 あなたの
映像を特定の方法で見せますが、私が
別のオシリスの女を好きになった
場合は、ビジョン10を
試してみます。 このうち
、このワークフロー
は非常に酔っ払っています。
これを実際にすばやく試してみましょう。
これは私のコメディのセットアップで
あり、現在多くのことが
適用され
ていますが、これ
を白黒スタイルのlutに変更したい場合
は そうするので、今すぐプログラムでそれを実行しましょう。それで、
luts
3d lut osirisに移動します。
最初
に最初の画像を選択し
ます。これで、全体的にかなり見栄えがするので、これから実行します。
これを右クリックして、
3d lut 33ポイントキューブを生成すると言います。生成する
ので
、この特定の
スタイルの画像用に独自のlutを作成します。 これ
を白黒と呼び、デスクトップ
のポケットシネマカメラファイルに保存
し
ます。これで、物事が
本当にクール
になります。 これを行う方法は
、私たちが見たコンバーターにほんの少しの基本的なusbusbケーブルを接続するつもりです
先ほど、ここに行きましょう。
基本的なusb usbケーブルだけでこのデバイスをコンピューターに接続しました。
モニターに戻ると、
これがsdiからhdmi6gへのデバイスであることが表示されます。
私がここをクリックすると
、ビデオ用のこのタブがあり、
3d lutを1つまたは2つ
ロードして、このデバイスに3d lutを
再度ロードできるようにします。つまり、デスクトップポケットシネマをロードする
場合、このコメディlutを使用するのではなく、
カメラの
黒と白を
開いて保存します。
これ
に戻ったら、
この
ルックにlutが適用されているので、
すぐに実際に移動して、
どのように見えるかを確認します。
だから今私のコメディビデオ
はこの白黒の外観が適用され
て
おり、alt doganは地獄のよう
に滑らかです
。同じ部屋で同じ部屋な
ので、非常に簡単に
独自のカスタムを作成できます。 見
てからそれを選択して
、来てください たくさん覚えておい
てください。実際にこれがリアルタイムでどのように見えるかを確認できる
ので、
これから開いて
みます。申し訳ありませんが、すぐに白黒に戻り
ます。
黒と白のテストと私がこの画像に行くと、私は私のコンピュータ画面でこれをしなければなら
ないのであなたたちはこれを見ることができません
が、私がlutを変更するとコメディのセットアップからの画像がどれほど劇的に変化するかを見
てください
別のlut
をコメディーlutに変更し、
これを押すと、1〜2秒のように再度ロードするのに1秒かかり
ますが、以前と
は100％異なって見えるので、
実際に切り替えましょう
白黒の外観にすばやく移行
できるので、カメラに必要なあらゆる種類
の外観を作成でき
ます。また、この製品を使用してカメラに直接適用できます。
このsdiからhdmiへの
コンバーターです。これはそうではありません。
あなたがしようとしているなら本当に本当に信じられないほどのum製品
特定の外観を探し
て、カラーグレーディングについてかなりの量を知っています。
実際に
は、キックのためだけに、
これに切り替えて、
実際にはスキップ
します。 さらに、
私たちは本当にすばやく試すことができ
ます。これは
、ミニコンバーター内でロットをオンまたはオフにする方法です。
これを押すと、
何に戻るかを教えてくれます
。このカメラを変更します。 カメラ
3に切り替えます。これを
オンにします。これができるはずです。
このデバイスのこの小さなスイッチを
今すぐ
オンにすると、コメディーカメラに適用されているlutがオン/オフになり
ます。 ブームをオフに
すると、お分かりのように完全にフラットに見えます。
オンに戻すと、
本当に見栄えがするので、
何
でも選択できるので、作成したい外観を選択し
て、このミニsdiで適用できます。
ええ、sdiからhdmiへのコンバーター
です。これも非常に強力です。
ビデオを好きなように見せて
ください。クリエイターの
場合、私のようなYouTuberの場合は、
色
やセットアップ、ビデオの
見た目とサウンドを美しく見せる
ことなどを知っています。これは非常に重要なことです。
だから
、これも私の内なる
アーティストですが、私は私のビデオ
が特定の方法で見えるのが好きです
私はこの
画像をそれがそうであるように見せるために
長い時間を費やしました
画像はそのよう
に見えますが
、これらは
ワークフローを高速化し、これらの
さまざまなこと
を行うために使用するさまざまなデバイスです。
次に、ある種の最終的なデバイスを紹介します。
さらに30
分間、たくさんの質問に答え
てください。これらの特定の製品に関する質問に答え
られるといいのですが、最後に
紹介する製品は
これです。これについては、
ルームツアーのセットアップで説明しました。 少しbi  tしかし、これは
ウルトラスタジオレコーダー
3gと呼ばれ、小さな雷のサインが付いていることがわかります。
これには、こちら側にサンダーボルトポートが
あり、こちら側には
、hdmi
入力とsdi入力がありますが、
これにより、
このカメラをここで知っている場合、これはこの特定のショットに使用するの
と同じモデルのカメラ
です
が
、以前は行っていたものであり、ほとんどの
人が
誰かが言ったことは vapeそれ
はvapeではありません私はあなたが何を指しているのかわかりませんが
、彼らがyoutube
ビデオまたはほとんどのビデオ
を撮影するとき
、それは間違いなくほとんどの人ではありません これを持って
、これらのアダプターの1つと同じように
接続し、コンピューター
に接続するときにこれをコンピューターに接続します。
次に、ファイルを転送する必要が
あります。私が
使用するファイルは、proreshqファイルであるためです。 非常に大きいので
、作成するたびに コメディービデオ
私は約100ギガバイトのファイルになります。
なぜなら、私は
愚かで、行を適切に配信できないため、各行に多くのテイクを行うからです。
コンピューター
このカメラから出ているこのhdmiケーブルを
今すぐ接続すると、sdカードを使用してファイルをデスクトップに転送するのではなく、ビデオの転送が完了するまで約20分待つ必要があります。
それをこのポートに接続するの
ではなく、このコンバーターまたはレコーダーのhdmiポート
をコンピューターに接続すると
、ビデオをコンピューターのデスクトップに直接保存できる
ので
、会社から100ギガバイトのファイルを転送する必要はありません。
私の会社のカメラを私のコンピューターに
直接ファイルを
コンピューターに保存できることを残念に思います。そのため、主な3
つまたは4つの主要な
ポイントは、このセットアップからポイントを奪い、
blackmagic製品をどのように使用するか 私のビデオを編集すること
は、
彼らがあなたが望む種類の外観を作成
することを可能にする彼らのカメラに非常に専門的な機能を持っ
ているということです。 ポストで
ビデオを編集
していて、ポストでもカラーグレードを適用する必要が
ありました。コンピューターが処理するのに
約
20分または30分
かかり、最後にビデオ映像を転送する必要がありました。
私のカメラから
これらのドングルの1つにあるsdカードを介してコンピューターに到達したので
、約20
分と30分でした。今日のビデオで今日
話したこれらのさまざまなデバイスを
使用すると、
すでに行われているビデオを録画できます。 色が
修正
され、ビデオファイルのオーディオファイルにオーディオが
含まれている
ので、それをデスクトップに直接録音できるので、blackmagicから使用するこれらのさまざまな
製品
で少なくとも1時間節約できます 私が行うすべてのビデオに対する私たちの仕事です
。davinciresolveに戻ると
、davinciresolveで実行できる
クールで素晴らしいことがたくさんあり
ます。
ええと、ええと、
私は禅僧ではありません
が、それはアヒジランタン
です。
ワークフロー
は、従来の
方法よりもはるかに高速です。YouTubeを始めたときの方法で行った場合
、コンテンツクリエーターとして、
これらすべての製品が大好きで、仕事が
10倍簡単になります。
sdカードを使用し、
カラーグレードを付けて投稿
する場合の従来のワークフローのようなものですが、これらすべての製品を使用すると、
映像がコンピューターに到達する前にすべてを実行できる
ため、ビデオはほぼ完成したようになります。
私はwhe  ni
はカメラでレコードを打ち終えました。
今すぐに飛び込んできた
人のために、私がやるのは本当に速いかもしれません。このデバイスをもう一度説明します。
これはatem mini proと呼ばれ、
これは小さなもののようなものです。
ええと、
特にストリーミングとカメラの切り替え専用の専用コンピュータです
。2回押すか1回押す
とこのカメラ
に切り替わり、2回押すと
メインカメラがそのカメラに切り替わり、3回押すとメインカメラが切り替わります。
そのカメラに切り替え
ます。4を押すとデスクトップに切り替わります
が、このデバイスから直接ストリーミングして
いるので、現在はコンピューターからストリーミングしていません。
このデバイスに直接接続されているイーサネットケーブルがあります。
次に、このデバイスは
私のコンピューターを使用するのではなく、インターネットに信号を送信しているので
、ビデオをインターネットに送信するためにobsなどのプログラムを使用する必要はありませ
ん。 私はええと、私は嘘をつかないのが好きではないので、そのファン
keobs私は
これらのストリーミングプログラムのいずれもubsstudioが好きではない
ので、これもこのデバイス
によって私の生活がはるかに楽になり
、組み込みのスイッチング
も本当にクールで、最後に
やります この
製品について、おそらく一部の人々が
atem mini pro isoと呼ばれるより高いモデルを提供していることに興味を持っていることについて話し
てください。これにより、
このようにさまざまなカメラを切り替える
ことができますが、ファイルを保存することもできます
。  davinciはストリーミングデバイス自体から編集ファイルを解決します。つまり
、ストリーミング中に
cpuまたはgp
gpuが読み込まれない
ことを意味します。つまり、まさにそれが私のコンピューターを意味し
ます。このデバイスのために、コンピューター上でやりたいことが何でもでき
ます。 は
ストリームに関連するすべての処理を行っています
が、ハイエンドモデルには
、インタビューなどのように録画している場合に、さまざまなカメラを切り替えることができる機能があります。
ヒンジ
に切り替え
たいカメラ1に切り替えてから、
カメラ2に切り替えてから、
カメラ
3に切り替えてから、カメラ
4に切り替え
ます。これは、通常の方法で行うことです。
インタビュー
ですが、ハイエンドモデルでは
、編集ファイルを保存して
、インタビューが終了した後
、4つの異なるビデオファイルすべてを手動で同期するのではなく
、aからminiに保存されたファイルを保存できます。 プロisoそれは
それを開く
とインタビュー
編集ファイルがすでに完成しているような編集ファイルになりますそして
あなたはあなたが望むどんな種類の微
調整もすることができます
それはゲームのようなインタビューのようなことをする人々のためのものです
-
機能を変更する
ので
、これらすべての説明を日本語で行うことができますか？時間切れではありません
私は約
20分25
20 20〜25分がストリームに残ってい
ますが、
それが私がこれらのさまざまな方法を使用する方法です 製品
このblackmagic4kシネマカメラ
このオリジナルのポケットシネマカメラこの
a10ミニプロ
ダヴィンチは解決しますそしてもちろんビデオ
も私がこのカメラに行くと私が実際にこれを上に向けることができるものを教えてくれれば
それは私が
コメディービデオを撮影
し
てから、マイクとすべてを備えた壁を邪魔しない
ようにして、カメラ
がそこに下がるようにします。これは現在
、a2miniproにも接続されています。
だから私はこれらのさまざまな
製品を
使って効果的な方法でビデオを撮影して編集し、
私が行こうとしている非常に具体的な外観を得る方法です
ああ私はこれが起こっていたことを忘れ
まし
た
これはこのビデオが
youtubeに残り
ますので、今からいくつかの質問に答えます。
おそらく多くの人が
いると思うので、これ
は
日本のライブストリームの時間
です。atemがobsと互換性があるかどうか知っています
か？ ドン 作曲のための外部処理を使用しないで
くださいええと、コンポ作曲は私の
ウィニーPCをストリーミングのためにはるかに実行可能にするでしょう
はい、答えははいですa2 mini pro
はポートの1つにusbc出力も持っている
ので、あなたは見ることができません
このカメラの角度ですが、これ
にはusbc出力があり、それを
コンピューターに接続する
と
、Webカメラとして表示されるため、
開いているobsやobs studio、または
それが何であれ、それを知ることができます。
新しい入力を
選択してウェブカメラblackmagica10mini pro
を選択すると、obs内でa2 mini proを使用
できるので、答えは「はい」です。
あなたが誰であるかはわかりませんが、その
タイトルには抵抗できませんでした。
私は犬です。YouTubeで
コメディックスタイルのコメディックな日本のビデオ
を試してみ
ています。それで、ユーチューブとパトレオン以外は何をしますか。
ええと
、ユーチューブとパトレオンですが、誰かが言った
あなたはどんなビデオゲームでもプレイするので、今度は
あなた
に追加のことを本当に素早く見せます私はこの入力を抜くつもりです
これは私の
コンピューター入力
です私はこの本当に速いプラグを抜くつもりです
このカメラに切り替えて、コンピューターの
プラグを抜い
て、これ
がまだストリーミングされていることを
願っています。うまくいけば、
私たちはまだ生きているように見えます。
私のプレイステーションに接続されている
ので、私たちが行くなら
、それは正しいプラグだと思います。
そうすれば
、このセットアップからビデオゲームを
ストリーミング
することもできます。 少しでも
簡単にストリーミングできます
。たとえば、
私はこのゲームが大好きです。ファイナル
ファンタジーviiなので
、自転車に乗っているときにゲームをプレイすることがよく
あります。音声は、音声レベルが問題ないように見えるはずです。
今
ですが、このデバイスをここで再びミニプロに使用できます
y ゲームキャプチャデバイスとしても使用できる
ので、今は
プレイステーション4
がこれに接続されており、4を押すと
プレイステーションが表示され、
まだ画面に表示され
ています。 コメントをすばやく確認するには
、ゲームの
音量が大きすぎます。申し訳ありませんが
、少し下げて
、ゲームをミュートしてから、
元に戻します。 これを
オフにしますが、ええ、
私はビデオゲームをプレイします。ファイナルファンタジー7をプレイします。
これは私のお気に入りのゲームであり
、ゲームをストリーミングするために
a2miniproをよく使用します。 彼が自転車に乗っているときにゲームをプレイしていると言って
くださいええと、私はこの
カメラに戻ります本当に速い
ええと、多分あなたたちはこれ
を
見ることが
できます ショットでは、
それは
エクササイズバイクであり、ファイナルファンタジー7をプレイしているときに、v以外の理由でそれに乗るというものです。
ideo編集作業
ええ静止したエアロ
バイク
はありません私はあまり自由な時間が
ないので、今のようにベビーシッターはここに
いますええと、あなたたちがa10ミニプロで興味を持っているかもしれないもう1つのクールなもの
モニターの入力を変更することもできる
ので、
これは今
のところプログラムのセットアップのようなものですが
、
プレイステーションのよう
に見たい場合はそれを行うことができます。
あなたは私のコメディーカメラを知っています私
はこれらのええと異なるカメラのいずれかを切り替えることができますが
、ストリーミングするときは通常
、この特定のメニューを使用するのが最善
です。あなたが見ることができるさまざまなカメラのそれぞれを本当によく
見ることができるからです 何が起こっているのか、また
、ストリームのデータレートが放送中のように見えるように見える
こともわかります。それはうまくいっていることを知っている
ので、それはあなたが選択できるa10miniproのもう1つの
クールな機能です。
の出力hdmi信号 デバイスも
同様に
、
patreonとyoutubeで家族を快適に育てることができ
ます。私はpatreonシリーズでかなりうまくやってきたので、今
はうまくいってい
ますが、それは明らかに各人とは異なります。
非常に長い間、私は2つの
仕事をうまく
やらなければなりませんでした3つの仕事の種類私はYouTube
ビデオをやりました私はapuでフルタイムの仕事をしました
そしてそれから私はこのようなpatreonphoneticsのレッスンもしました
そしてそれから約2、3年後
に グラインディングとあなたは2、2、3、1、2の仕事をしていることを知っています
私はフル
タイムで
働くことを最終的に私はapuで働くのをやめ
てYouTube側に集中する
ことができるように
なりました 大学で働いているので
、いつvtuberのキャリアを開始します
か？ええと、ええと、ハリス・ヘラーが
最近行ったビデオで使用していたミキサーを正確に
把握する必要があります。
私はbする必要があります 私のvtuberデビューを作ることができ
ます。他に他に何か質問がありますか
？
もう一度ストリーミングしたり
、私が再び使用するさまざまなカメラ製品のいずれかについて、
私は
今このストリームの4つの異なる
カメラに接続しています。
私のプレイステーションも接続されてい
ますが、そのためのオーディオはオフになって
いるので大丈夫です
、そして私はこの製品を使用して
すべての間を循環するので、
これを使って
効果的にライブストリームを行うことができます
その
素敵なトランジションに戻ってオフにし
ます。そうですね、このセットアップ全体のコスト
は本当に良い質問
です。私にとっては、使用済みのものを購入する方が良いと
思いました。このカメラを購入した
ように、これは次のようになります。 このカメラ
は2013年に発売されたので、インターネット上で今話題になっている多くの人
がこの新しいソニーa7 iiiのように話している
ように、キヤノンのように私はそれがキヤノンのeosrだと思います
ドル5トー
8kビデオのように撮影する米国ドルのカメラ
このカメラは
2013年に発売され、1080pしかありませんが、品質
は非常識で、400 umのように使用して購入しました。
おそらく、500だったと思いますが、その上にあるこのレンズ
は ええと、それは文字通り百
ドル
だったので
、あなたが購入している機器について十分に知っているなら、あなたは
安い機器を安く使うことができますが
、私
がまた買った私のコメディービデオのために私が使っているこのカメラも同様の結果を得るのに良い機器を使うことができます この
カメラ
は、文字通りまったく同じカメラ
を
使用し、500も使用されていたので、使用したすべてのレンズを購入
しました。使用したすべてのカメラ
を購入しました
。
多分それはここにあったと思いますええ
、この小さなデバイスsdiからhdmiへの
コンバーター
これは200のようなものだったので
、本当に高価なコンピューターを購入するのではなく、
これを購入し
ました。ビデオで色補正を行う必要はありません。
私のviをレンダリングする必要があります deos
だから、4000ドルか5000ドルのコンピューターのようにもう一度買うのではなく、
私はこれを200
ドルで購入し、
レンダリングプロセスを完全に排除し
ました。
このカメラblackmagicjapan
は、私がすべてをblackmagicで撮影することを知ったので、このカメラを貸してくれました
。現在、私たちは
一緒に仕事をしているので、
いくつかの製品を貸してくれています。
このビデオの冒頭で、
このストリームが後でアップするかどうかを見てみましょ
う。はい、別のシャツを着たこの男を見るのはとてもクレイジー
です。私が処理しているすべてのビデオで
、大まかにアーカイブするための大量のストレージがあり
ます
か？ ええ、私は
ネットワーク接続
ストレージを持っていて、それは
私がかなり最近購入した16テラバイト
だと思いますが、ネットワーク接続ストレージ
はあなたが得ることができるほど高価ではないことを知っています あなたのコンピュータ用
の非常に高速なssdのように購入するよりもはるかに安い
ためのまともなええとネットワーク接続ストレージしかしええと、ええと、私は
あなたたち
が私がいるこの机のような面白いものを見たいかどうか見てみましょう 今使って
いるのは
これもスタンディングデスク
です。ボタンを押すとカメラが取り付けられているので、
持ち上げるととてもスムーズに
見えます。おっと、また後でお会いし
ましょう。
ええと、通常の設定の
エレベーターに
戻ります。使用済みカメラはどこで入手しましたか。
アマゾンジャパンで両方の使用済みカメラを
購入しましたが、ebayやamazonなどでオンラインで使用したものを購入できます。
再び400ドル
500ドルのように
私はそれらを300ドルのように安く見ました
そして彼らは2013年に
再び出てきた信じられないほどのカメラです
が彼らはまだ私の
意見では彼らのイメージはまだ
たくさん見えると思います もっとc
現在出ている99台のカメラの
ように非現実的な
のでええとええとbh写真bh写真も
ええとこれらのデバイスを持っているでしょうええとあなたはプライム
メンバー
ですええとええ私はアマゾンプライムメンバーですええと
あなたはあなたの青を変える予定ですか？ イエティスはxlrマイク用ですええそうii
はビデオの前半でこれに対処しましたが、
ゴミの味から彼は
私がブラックマジックを使用しているかブラックマジックを使用して
いない
こと
を知りました 適切なxlrマイク
最近私はこのカメラまたは
このマイクをアップグレードしましたこれは
オクタバmk12と呼ばれています私
はそれがumと呼ばれているものだと思います
そしてそれはxlrマイクですそして
このカメラは画面の真ん中にあり
ます右 今
、私がこれを指しているこのカメラには
、ミニミニxlr入力が組み込まれているので、
このような素敵なxlrマイクをカメラに直接接続
できます。これも、ビデオまたはオーディオについてかなりの量を知っている場合です。
あなたはそれがそれだということを知っています
非常に大したことなので
、もちろん、コナーがそれを提案したのはコナーでした。コナーとドーガンが目
を光らせているときは、それ
だけです。
数日間の撮影ですべてのクリップ
と非常に多くのファイルをどのように管理しますか。 私はタグ付けを始め
ましたが、
ファイルの整理
は非常に簡単です。コメディーの
セットアップが2つしかないので
、このセットアップをコメディーにセットアップし
てから、デスクにこのカメラをセットアップさせます。
私があなたが知っているようにファイルに適切に名前を付けている限り
あなたがjapan.movにいる34の兆候
ファイルの整理は本当に簡単です私は
あなたが私のyoutubeの友達の多くを知っている
ようではありません
海外の日本
では、
外出先で
外出先で街に出て、
何時間もの映像を撮影
し、さまざまな
テイク
から選択するビデオを作成していることをご存知でしょう。すべてを整理するのは非常に困難です。
その映像ですが
、私のすべての映像は常に1つの
巨大なファイルなので、組織について心配する必要はありません。
基本的
には、ゴミの
味の
ポッドキャストに参加し
ますか。
私のカメラまたは私のカメラではなく私の
コンピュータを購入しました私は私のimacを新しく購入しましたそして私は私のipadproを
購入しました
ので私は今このipadproからコメントを読んでいます
それから
また私は自分のコンピューターを
新しく購入しましたが、私が購入した技術のほとんど
が使用されており、
このBlackmagic Pocket Cinema
Camera 4kのような
Blackmagic製品とBlackMagic製品は
、それらが提供する機能セットに対して安価であることが知られて
いるので、
私は一種です この時点で繰り返し
ます
が、これが2013年に1000ドルで発売されたとき、この
カメラは、同じum機能セットのbecauを備えた他のどのカメラよりも5000ドル安いと発表された価格だと思います
当時、他のカメラは
1万ドルのように生で撮影できなかったので、
それは本当に前代未聞でした。それが
、私が彼らの製品を愛している理由の1つです。それは、
私が彼らの会社をとても愛している理由の1
つです。
他の会社に名前を付けたくないのです
が、すでにそこにあるものからお金を稼ぎ、ブラックマジックを革新しないのではなく、
常に大丈夫だと言ってきました
。
この新しいギアをアップグレードまたはリリースするこの新しいギアは
、他の
カメラ会社がおそらく
3〜4年ほどリリースしないとはいえ、さらにクレイジーです。
最近
、たとえば12kカメラをリリースしたばかりで
、他にはありません。 カメラ会社は長い間
12kカメラをリリースする予定です
それはやり過ぎだと思います明らかに
私は自分のビデオを1080p、時には4kでしか撮影しません
が、
それらは非常に素晴らしい機能をもたらします
できるだけ多くの人に
できるだけ多くの技術を
持たせて、
できるだけ摩擦を少なくして好きな動画を作成できるようにするために、非常に高額
です。だからこそ、私は
会社のように私が会社をとても好きな理由の1
つええと、セットアップでノイズ
を減らす方法についてもっと深く掘り下げることができますか？
エコーはかなり悪いと言いまし
たええと、私の部屋の外からのノイズはどうですか？
本当に高価なマイクであるassuresmsm7bのように600ドルのように費やすよりも
はるかに安いマイクを200マイクのように購入しました
そして私はこれらの
アマゾンサウンドパネルのようになりましたそして私
はそれらで私の部屋を覆いました
悪いマイクでサウンド処理されていない部屋を持っているよりも、まともなマイクでサウンド処理されている部屋を持っている方がはるかに良いので
、私がルミを持っているのを見てみましょう
x 4kを撮影できるカメラとしてはかなり良い
ようですが、300ユーロ程度のバッグで使用しました。なぜ、
誰もが12kカメラを必要とする
ので
、8kカメラや4kカメラが必要なのと同じ理由です。
さらに言えば、これらの追加のピクセル
がある場合
、ショットを少し間違ってフレームに収めた
場合や、後でズームインした場合に画像の一部をズームインしたい場合のように、配信
できることを意味します。 ピクセル化されているので、
あなたが
それをうまく撮影しているなら、それはプロの
カメラです
。それは、カメラの
予算が5万ドルのよう
な映画のようなものですが、映画
を撮影していて
、 俳優数百万ドルえ
えと、あなたはええとズームインする能力が必要です、
またはあなたは事後
の画像のフレーミングがどこで変わる
かを知っていますそしてそれ
はそれが12kまたは8kまたは再び4kが
することですそれは追加の解像度
がすることです 私が言うほとんどの映画は
プロバです bly
は8kで配信される
ので、12kを使用すると
、
8kを使用して
柔軟性を
得ることができます。4kを使用すると、1080pを使用して柔軟性を得ることができます。そのため、ハリスのビデオが期待されていたので、どうなるでしょうか。
寄付の方法
将来
的には現代日本語
が自国
語になる
可能性についてのあなたの考え 100年か
そうだね日本ではおそらく100年くらいは
シンガポールのよう
に人々が定期的に
中国語と英語を切り替えるようなもの
になるだろうか、それ
は
スペインとタガログ
語のスペイン語のフィリピンだったのだと私は確信している とタガログ
語言語が混同されている場合は
申し訳ありませんが、100年ほどで、
人々は
おそらく
、 また、日本人は
おそらくたくさんのローンの言葉を持っているでしょうが、
ええと、
私は2分で行か
なければなりませんでした誰かが
私のカメラのセットアップについてもう一度答えることができるどんな種類の最終的な質問もあり
ます私はこれを使ってい
ますa-10 mini プロがここに
いて、
このビデオをyoutubeにストリーミングして
います。コメディーのセットアップには、4つの異なる入力
があります。
このカメラを持っています。このカメラを使って、
これを撮影して
います。 私のプレイステーション
は、少し前にそれを示していたので接続しましたが、
現在a10
mini proでストリーミングしています。これはストリーミング用の素晴らしいデバイスで
あり、
コンテンツクリエーター
にとって、次に購入したいカメラは何ですか。
私は別のカメラを手に入れるつもり
はありません私は別のカメラを必要としません
私が今持って
いるカメラは十分すぎるほどですそして私は作家として
私がaaのようになることを試みるよりも私の執筆に集中することがはるかに重要だと思います
4k
カメラまたは8kカメラまたはyoのような この
ようなことは何でも知っています。
私は自分の執筆に集中し、
この
9歳のカメラを知っているように、これらの優れた製品を使用して私の執筆を配信する必要
があります。
ほとんどのクリエイターは
、ストリームデッキよりも強力な
アテムである
ため、利用することもできます。ミニストリーミングコンピューターとして使用できるので、アテムが好きです。
一方、ストリームデッキ
は、あのようなものです。
obsのようなプログラム内でさまざまなことを実行できるデバイスですが、このストリーム
デッキが
ここにあります。現在、obsを使用していません。
このデバイスから直接ストリーミングしているので
、このデバイスに直接接続されているイーサネットケーブルがあります。
だから私はアテムが本当に好きなのです
中古のblackmagicjapanを購入したne歳のカメラは、
このカメラをこの4k
blackmagicポケットシネマカメラに貸してくれるほど親切
でした。ストリームの冒頭でそれについて話しました
が、
blackmagicテクノロジーは
彼らが作ったものです。 このカメラのようにテクノロジーが溢れ
ている
この4kblackmagicPocket Cinema Cameraに
は多くの機能があり
、次のようにyoutubeを起動しようとしている場合は、2000または3000カメラのようになることを心配する必要はありません。
あなたはこのカメラを手に入れました、あるいは
この古いカメラでさえもこれは
400ドルのようでし
たあなたは設定されています私は400カメラを使ってこの
カメラを使って私のすべてのyoutubeビデオを撮影します
残念ながらアフィリエイトリンクはありませんが
、このビデオのビデオの説明で今日話したすべてのブラックマジック製品をリンクして
いるので、先に進んでそれをチェックして
、残念ながら10を
節約することができます 私
今すぐ行かなくちゃ